OK. I think we all can agree, this sounds really, really bad. Four guys from Newburgh, New York plant explosives at a synagogue and a Jewish community center in the Bronx. And they're arrested-- this is three months ago, they were arrested in May. They also, it turns out, had plans to fire Stinger surface-to-air missiles at military planes.
好的。我想我们都同意，这听起来真的很糟糕。来自纽约纽堡的四个人在布朗克斯的一座犹太会堂和一个犹太社区中心放置了爆炸物。他们被捕了——那是三个月前的事，他们在五月被捕。事实证明，他们还计划用“毒刺”地对空导弹袭击军用飞机。
On the face of it, this case looks like a pretty shocking criminal act.
从表面上看，这起案件看起来是一起相当令人震惊的刑事犯罪。
Aziz Huq writes about the government's legal strategy in the war on terror. He's also the lawyer defending prisoners in a couple of these kinds of cases. And he says that, when you dig into the details of this particular case, it starts to look different.
阿齐兹·哈克（Aziz Huq）撰写过关于政府在反恐战争中法律策略的文章。他也是为几起此类案件中的被告提供辩护的律师。他说，当你深入挖掘这个特定案件的细节时，情况就开始显得不同了。
Basically, what you have here is the most recent in a series of cases in which a alleged terrorism conspiracy is initiated, and pushed along, by a government informant. An older man, somebody in his 40s, who's wealthy coming to a mosque--
基本上，这是最近发生的一系列案件中的最新一起，其中所谓的恐怖主义阴谋是由政府线人发起并推动的。一个40多岁、富有的人来到清真寺——
This is the informant?
这是线人吗？
This is an informant. Coming to a mosque, finding people who are on the periphery of crime, and encouraging them and walking them toward somewhat an act of terrorist violence.
这是一名线人。他来到清真寺，寻找那些处于犯罪边缘的人，鼓励他们并引导他们走向某种恐怖主义暴力行为。
And so the informant in this case, when he came upon these men, did they have this plan to attack the synagogue?
那么，这个案子里的线人在遇到这些人时，他们有袭击犹太会堂的计划吗？
As far as anyone can tell, no.
就目前所知，没有。
In other words, he wasn't stumbling upon an active terror cell?
换句话说，他并不是偶然发现了一个活跃的恐怖组织？
Well, no. What we know is that, on the one hand, here you have a case where a group of people have done something, clearly reprehensible, clearly criminal. On the other hand, it's not clear whether absent this tremendous amount of money and time that is coming out of the government's coffers, there would have been any crime in the first place.
嗯，没有。我们所知道的是，一方面，这是一个群体做了一些显然应受谴责、显然是犯罪的事情；另一方面，如果不投入政府财政中那笔巨大的资金和时间，最初是否会发生任何犯罪还不清楚。
The plastic explosives used in the bombing were actually provided by the government, through the informant, and they were fakes. The Stinger missile came through the informant, and it was incapable of firing. And the informant also drove them to the bombing. The perpetrators, meanwhile, are described in press accounts as sad sack petty criminals, whose previous crimes were snatching purses and trying to sell drugs to undercover cops, that kind of thing.
爆炸中使用的塑胶炸弹实际上是由政府通过线人提供的，而且是假的。“毒刺”导弹也是通过线人提供的，而且无法发射。线人还开车送他们去进行爆炸。与此同时，新闻报道将这些肇事者描述为毫无希望的小罪犯，他们之前的罪行无非是抢夺钱包和试图向便衣警察兜售毒品之类的勾当。
One is described as being addicted to crack and coke for years. Another took medication for schizophrenia and was reported to keep bottles of his own urine in his apartment. None of them seem to have ties to any known terrorist organizations. And this case is not unique. It comes out of a strategy that our government developed after September 11. The government wanted, understandably, to stop terrorists before they attacked. But, of course-- think about that for a second. What a difficult job. How can you find somebody and stop them and lock them up for something before they actually do it?
其中一人被描述为多年来沉迷于快克和可卡因。另一人因精神分裂症服用药物，据报道在他的公寓里藏着装有自己尿液的瓶子。他们似乎都没有与任何已知的恐怖组织有联系。而且这个案例并非孤例。它源于我们政府在9/11事件后制定的一项策略。政府理所当然地想要在恐怖分子发动袭击前阻止他们。但是，当然——试想一下。这是一项多么困难的工作。你怎么能在某人真正行动之前找到他们、阻止他们并把他们关起来呢？
Well, what the government decided to do was go after people who seemed like they might someday get involved in a terrorist conspiracy. With any charges that it could make stick. At least it would get those people off the street. And sometimes that meant sending in an informant, to nudge suspicious people into doing something, like what those men in Newburgh did. Well, today on our program we have the amazing story of one of the first cases after 9/11 that did this.
政府决定采取的办法是针对那些看起来将来可能会卷入恐怖主义阴谋的人。用任何能定罪的指控。至少这样能把这些人从街头清除掉。有时这意味着派出一名线人，引导那些可疑的人去做些什么，就像纽堡那几个人做的那样。嗯，今天在我们的节目中，我们要讲述9/11事件后第一批采取这种做法的案件之一的精彩故事。
The justice department went after a guy who hadn't done anything wrong. An informant helped him commit a crime, and they convicted him.
司法部针对一个并没有做任何错事的人展开了行动。一名线人帮助他犯下了罪行，然后他们对他进行了定罪。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. This is a story that takes place in the world of international illegal arms sales. The world of wiretaps, and informants, and prosecutors. You are going to be hearing FBI surveillance tape. You'll hear from the man who got put away, and from the US Attorney who led the team that put him away. Petra Bartosiewicz has the story, which we are devoting our whole show to today. This originally ran on our program in 2005, right after the trial.
来自芝加哥WBEZ，这里是《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。这是一个发生在全球非法武器交易世界中的故事。一个充满窃听器、线人和检察官的世界。你将听到FBI的监控录音。你将听到那个被关进监狱的人的讲述，以及领导团队将其定罪的美国联邦检察官的讲述。佩特拉·巴托谢维奇（Petra Bartosiewicz）带来了这个故事，我们今天整个节目都将致力于此。这期节目最初于2005年、审判结束后不久在我们的节目中播出。
What you're about to hear is a victory speech, almost four years in the making. It's April 23 of this year, and the US Attorney is giving a press conference on the steps of the federal courthouse in Newark, announcing the conviction of Hemant Lakhani.
你接下来要听到的是一场酝酿了近四年的胜利演讲。那是今年的4月23日，美国联邦检察官正在纽瓦克联邦法院大楼的台阶上举行新闻发布会，宣布赫曼特·拉卡尼（Hemant Lakhani）被定罪。
Good morning, my name is Christopher Christie. I'M the United States Attorney for the district of New Jersey. The jury has spoken, and Hemant Lakhani is not a women's clothing salesman. He's been found guilty on all counts for lending material support, attempting to lend material support to terrorists, money laundering, smuggling, illegal brokering of weapons.
早上好，我是克里斯托弗·克里斯蒂（Christopher Christie）。我是新泽西州地区的美国联邦检察官。陪审团已经做出了裁决，赫曼特·拉卡尼不是一名女装销售员。他因提供物质支持、试图向恐怖分子提供物质支持、洗钱、走私、非法武器经纪等所有指控均被判有罪。
Today is a triumph for the Justice Department in the war against terror. I don't know that anyone can say that the state of New Jersey, and this country, is not a safer place without Hemant Lakhani trotting around the globe attempting to broker arms deals.
今天是司法部在反恐战争中的一次胜利。我不认为有人能说，如果没有赫曼特·拉卡尼在全球范围内试图斡旋武器交易，新泽西州和这个国家不会是一个更安全的地方。
Later the very same day, in the Passaic County lockup, sits the convicted terrorist sympathizer Hemant Lakhani.
当天晚些时候，在帕塞伊克县（Passaic County）监狱里，坐着被定罪的恐怖主义同情者赫曼特·拉卡尼。
[MAN CRYING]
[男人哭泣声]
Hemant Lakhani is a liar, a shameless braggart, a snob. He's amoral, selfish and he's greedy. But the thing is, if you hear his story, it's hard to believe that on his own he would have ever succeeded in buying or delivering a missile to a terrorist group. In fact, he's an amazingly incompetent illegal arms trader. And it's not at all clear that the world, or New Jersey, are any safer with him off the streets.
赫曼特·拉卡尼是个骗子、厚颜无耻的吹牛大王、势利小人。他道德沦丧、自私且贪婪。但问题是，如果你听了他的故事，很难相信他能凭一己之力成功购买或向恐怖组织交付一枚导弹。事实上，他是一个极其无能的非法军火商。而且，完全不清楚把他从街上抓走后，这个世界或新泽西州是否变得更安全了。
How is Mrs. Lakhani?
拉卡尼夫人还好吗？
She's OK. I'm going to talk to her later.
她还好。我稍后会和她谈谈。
That's me, comforting him. Telling him I'm sorry. That his wife is going to be OK. The truth is, I'm not sure I'm exactly sorry. And I don't really know if his wife is going to be OK. But when an old man is sitting next to you, crying like that, reminiscing about their life together, what else are you going to say?
那是我们在安慰他。告诉他我很抱歉。他的妻子会没事的。事实是，我不确定我是否真的感到抱歉。我也不知道他的妻子是否真的会没事。但是当一个老人坐在你身边，像那样哭泣，回忆着他们在一起的生活时，你还能说什么呢？
By putting me away for 100 years, or 5 years or 50 years, what do they think they are going to do? They think that terrorism is going to stop? I have nothing to do with terrorism. I am not Muslim. I am not a part of Al Qaeda, or Hamas or of Hamas or anything. And what do I want against America? What have I got against America? why?
把我关进监狱100年，或者5年，或者50年，他们认为他们能做什么？他们认为恐怖主义就会停止吗？我和恐怖主义毫无关系。我不是穆斯林。我不是基地组织、哈马斯或任何组织的成员。我反对美国什么？我反对美国什么？为什么？
Hemant Lakhani is 70 years old. He is Indian, but he's a British citizen who lived in London for decades. And all his life, he's made his living by being a salesman of one sort or another. Clothing, rice, oil, armored personnel carriers-- more on that later-- and lately, it seems, an illegal shoulder fired missile. So how did a salesman, a guy with no criminal history whatsoever, become a target in the war on terror?
赫曼特·拉卡尼今年70岁。他是印度人，但他是已经在伦敦生活了数十年的英国公民。他一辈子都是靠做各种销售为生。服装、大米、石油、装甲运兵车——稍后会详述——最近似乎还包括非法肩扛式导弹。那么，一个没有犯罪记录的推销员是如何成为反恐战争的目标的呢？
Bad timing has a lot to do with it. As it happened, the US Attorney who sent him to prison, Christopher Christie, was nominated to his job by President Bush on September 10, 2001. His office has this huge conference room with giant windows facing lower Manhattan.
时机不佳有很大关系。碰巧的是，将他送进监狱的美国联邦检察官克里斯托弗·克里斯蒂，是在2001年9月10日被布什总统提名的。他的办公室有一个巨大的会议室，有着面向曼哈顿下城的巨大窗户。
We're sitting in my conference room, doing this interview, you look out those windows, you have an unobstructed view of Manhattan. And people sat in this conference room and watched both buildings collapse. And so the atmosphere, when I came in a few months later, after my confirmation was still one of real crisis and of real sadness. And it was enormously stressful. And, I can tell you, that in my first six months here, I was confronted on a weekly basis with a widow or a child who had lost their family. And in my own parish at home we lost two people. In my children's school, there were three parents who were killed.
我们坐在我的会议室里做这次采访，你望向窗外，可以毫无遮挡地看到曼哈顿。当时人们就坐在会议室里，看着两座大楼倒塌。所以当我几个月后上任时，那里的气氛依然充满真正的危机感和悲伤。压力非常大。我可以告诉你，在我上任的前六个月里，我每周都要面对一位失去家人的遗孀或孩子。在我家乡的教区，我们失去了两个人。在我孩子所在的学校，有三名家长被杀害。
And they look to you now. You're the US Attorney, and they look to you to say, are we safe? And so that was the atmosphere when you walked in. And that was the atmosphere under which Lakhani started. You've got to place everything that happens in the early parts of Lakhani in that context. That we were intent as prosecutors-- and I believe the agents felt this way too-- making sure it wasn't going to happen again.
现在他们仰仗着你。你是美国联邦检察官，他们看着你问，我们安全吗？这就是你走进那里时的气氛。这也是拉卡尼案开始时的背景。你必须把拉卡尼案初期发生的一切放在那个背景下。作为检察官，我们决心——我相信探员们也这么认为——确保这样的事情不会再次发生。
We clearly now had a brand new mandate from the President and the Attorney General. And  the mandate was prevent a terrorist attack. Not solve it after it happens, but preventive it. And I don't think people still understand what a sea change that was for federal law enforcement in this country.
我们现在显然得到了总统和司法部长全新的授权。授权就是防止恐怖袭击。不是在发生后解决它，而是预防它。我不认为人们现在仍然理解这对于这个国家的联邦执法来说是一个多么巨大的转变。
So it's understandable that Christie's interest was piqued when he heard a report from an informant about Hemant Lakhani his very first week on the job.
因此，当克里斯蒂在上任的第一周听到一份关于赫曼特·拉卡尼的线人报告时，他的兴趣被激发起来是可以理解的。
It was in a normal, weekly terrorism briefing on the fact that we had this informant who was telling us that there was someone who approached him regarding his willingness to broker missile sales.
那是在一次例行的每周恐怖主义简报会上，线人告诉我们，有人接触了他，询问他是否愿意斡旋导弹销售。
That informant is the next important piece of this story. To explain his part in it, we actually have to go back a couple decades, to Lahore, Pakistan. To an American Drug Enforcement Administration agent named Charles Lee. Lee was a former seminarian who, sitting on the toilet one day at school, happened to pick up a Reader's Digest and open it to a New York cop story called "Merchants of Heroin." He was so taken with the story that he quit the seminary the very next day and became a federal agent. He ended up stationed in Lahore.
那个线人是这个故事的下一个重要部分。要解释他在其中的作用，我们实际上得回到几十年前的巴基斯坦拉合尔。去见一位名叫查尔斯·李（Charles Lee）的美国缉毒局探员。李曾是一名修道院学生，有一天他在学校上厕所时，碰巧拿起一本《读者文摘》，翻到了一篇关于纽约警察的故事，名为《海洛因商人》。他被这个故事深深吸引，第二天就退学成了联邦探员。他最终被派驻在拉合尔。
One day, a contact brought this guy to his office, named Habib, who said he wanted to work for the US government on drug cases
有一天，一个联系人把这个叫哈比卜（Habib）的人带到了他的办公室，说他想为美国政府做毒品案件。
He talked about some people that we were quite interested in. I asked him about a particular individual up in northwest Frontier, that we'd had no success-- he was wanted in, I believe, at least two or three judicial districts. And he was already indicted. All we needed to do was get him out. But, you couldn't even get the army to go after these people up there. So, Habib said that he could get this person out.
他谈到了一些我们非常感兴趣的人。我问他关于西北边境的一个特定的人，我们一直没有成功——我相信他在至少两个或三个司法管辖区被通缉。他已经被起诉了。我们要做的就是把他带出来。但是，你连军队都无法调动去对付那里的人。所以，哈比卜说他能把这个人弄出来。
I thought, well, nothing could be a better acid test then to try that with Habib to begin with. Because if he could do that, he must be able to do just about anything. And here Habib comes along, and in no time flat, delivered this guy right out. Kaboom. We had him and well, it made a believer out of all of us. This guy obviously could do it.
我想，嗯，没有什么比先试着让哈比卜做这件事更好的压力测试了。因为如果他能做到这一点，他几乎能做到任何事情。哈比卜来了，没过多久，就把这个人带出来了。砰。我们抓住了他，嗯，这让我们所有人都相信了。这家伙显然能做到。
So that started it. So everybody loved Habib then.
事情就这样开始了。所以那时候每个人都喜欢哈比卜。
Habib turned out to be a great informant. For about a year and a half, he and Lee made case after case. Then, one day, Habib's cover was suddenly blown. A drug dealer tried to kill him. And Lee swooped in to save him. Within 24 hours, Habib and his family were in the US, but now he had no job and no support.
哈比卜后来成了一个伟大的线人。在大约一年半的时间里，他和李破获了一个又一个案子。然后有一天，哈比卜的卧底身份突然暴露了。一个毒贩试图杀他。李赶去救了他。24小时内，哈比卜和他的家人就来到了美国，但现在他没有工作，也没有支持。
So after awhile, he tracked down Lee, who, by then, had returned to the US and asked him if he could do DEA cases in the states. And they started working together again on drug cases. Lee also recommended him to the FBI, to use an informant on terrorism cases.
所以过了一段时间，他找到了当时已经回到美国的李，问他是否可以在美国从事缉毒工作。他们开始再次合作处理毒品案件。李还向FBI推荐了他，让他担任恐怖主义案件的线人。
But Lee says Habib wasn't on top of his game. And that came to light during one investigation, where Habib tried to incriminate a guy who, in Lee's words, was not a doper, period. Lee couldn't figure out what Habib's motive was for setting the guy up.
但李说哈比卜已经不在状态了。这在一次调查中被发现，哈比卜试图陷害一个李口中根本不是“瘾君子”的人。李想不通哈比卜陷害那个人的动机是什么。
When that happens, it calls into question this guy's abilities and his veracity. It calls everything into question. Asking him about it, he didn't have the answers. And when you don't have the answers in this game, that's good night. So rather than trying to second guess a bunch of that, you just close this guy out. That's the end of him. Unreliable.
当这种情况发生时，就会让人质疑这个人的能力和诚实。这让一切都受到了质疑。问起他时，他没有答案。当你在这种游戏中拿不出答案时，那就是晚安了。所以与其试着去猜测，不如直接切断这个线人。这就是他的终点。不可靠。
There were other disappointments. Lee started a rice importing business with Habib. He thought it would help get Habib on his feet, permanently. But pretty soon he found out Habib had ripped him off. He'd sold the same shipment twice, and Lee had to make good on $25,000 he'd stolen from a customer. And then he found out Habib had ripped off other people too. Had threatened people, said he could get people killed. Lee was floored. He cut off Habib completely.
还有其他的失望。李与哈比卜合伙开了一家大米进口生意。他以为这能帮助哈比卜永久地站稳脚跟。但没过多久他就发现哈比卜坑了他。他把同一批货卖了两次，李不得不赔偿他从客户那里偷走的25,000美元。然后他发现哈比卜还坑了其他人。威胁过别人，说他能让人丧命。李彻底震惊了。他完全切断了与哈比卜的联系。
He also typed up a nine-page letter about what he'd learned, and delivered it to Habib's FBI handler. Sometime after that the FBI deactivated Habib as one of its informants.
他还打了一封九页长的信，说明了他所学到的情况，并将其交给了哈比卜的FBI对接人。那之后不久，FBI就取消了哈比卜作为线人的资格。
But then, after 9/11, things changed at the FBI. Though the agency had been warned how unreliable Habib could be, his experience and language skills suddenly made him a hot property, and different FBI bureaus were fighting over him. He ended up in the Newark bureau, which is also the jurisdiction of US Attorney Chris Christie.
但是，在9/11事件后，FBI内部的情况发生了变化。尽管FBI已经被警告过哈比卜有多不可靠，但他的经验和语言能力使他突然成了抢手货，不同的FBI办事处都在争夺他。他最终进入了纽瓦克办事处，这也属于美国联邦检察官克里斯·克里斯蒂的管辖范围。
It's Habib who first spotted Hemant Lakhani and brought him to the attention of the FBI. When Lee heard about the case, he was stunned that the FBI was talking to Habib at all.
是哈比卜首先发现了赫曼特·拉卡尼并引起了FBI的注意。当李听到这个案子时，他非常震惊FBI竟然还在跟哈比卜接触。
I don't know. It went through my mind, I wonder how they can justify doing that? I wondered if it was a legit case. I'm sure these terrorism cases are exceedingly difficult to make. And exceedingly difficult to break into, and that therein lies the temptation to reactivate a guy like Habib. Maybe they took him out and dusted him off and put him back to work.
我不知道。我心想，不知道他们怎么证明这样做是合理的？我怀疑这是一个合法的案件。我相信这些恐怖主义案件极难立案，也极难打入内部，正因为如此，启用像哈比卜这样的人才会有诱惑力。也许他们把他重新起用，掸去灰尘，让他重新工作。
So here's how Habib ended up at the center of one of the biggest post 9/11 terrorism cases. Habib knew an Indian gangster, a suspected terrorist named Abdul Kayum. Kayum also knew Lakhani. Here's US attorney Chris Christie.
这就是哈比卜如何成为9/11后最大的恐怖主义案件之一的核心。哈比卜认识一个印度黑帮分子，一个名叫阿卜杜勒·卡尤姆（Abdul Kayum）的恐怖嫌疑人。卡尤姆也认识拉卡尼。下面是美国联邦检察官克里斯·克里斯蒂。
The ties that Lakhani was claiming to have to us, to the terrorist whose last was Kayum was one that was of particular interest to us. The fact that Kayum even knew who Lakhani was. You know, I don't know what a women's clothing salesman is doing being associated with someone like Kayum.
拉卡尼声称与我们、与以卡尤姆为首的恐怖分子有关联，这让我们特别感兴趣。卡尤姆甚至认识拉卡尼这个事实。你知道，我不知道一个女装推销员和像卡尤姆这样的人有什么关联。
A word here about Abdul Kayum. He's suspected of a series of bomb attacks in Bombay in 1993. Kayum's name is on terrorist watch lists around the world. And Lakhani's association with him is one of the most incriminating things about this case. And something Lakhani has never been able to explain away. What we do know is that in the fall of 2001, Kayum was sitting in Lakhani's hotel room in Dubai, a hotel they both regularly stayed at, Lakhani says, talking business.
这里提一下阿卜杜勒·卡尤姆。他被怀疑参与了1993年孟买的一系列炸弹袭击。卡尤姆的名字出现在世界各地的恐怖分子观察名单上。拉卡尼与他的联系是此案中最具罪证性的事情之一。这也是拉卡尼一直无法解释清楚的事情。我们所知道的是，在2001年秋天，卡尤姆坐在拉卡尼在迪拜的酒店房间里，他们两人经常住在那家酒店，拉卡尼说是在谈生意。
At the time, Lakhani's career was in something of a slump. He had been a successful clothing importer, but when that fell apart in the early 1980s, he went into other stuff. He bought a rice business, and later a small Indian airline, but those went under after a while too. He tried to recoup his losses by brokering various other deals. His latest one was an oil refinery deal. At the moment when he was sitting in the hotel room with Kayum, he was looking for oil investors.
当时，拉卡尼的职业生涯处于低谷。他曾是一名成功的服装进口商，但当那个生意在20世纪80年代初破产后，他就开始做其他事情。他买了一家大米公司，后来又买了一家小型印度航空公司，但过了一阵子也都倒闭了。他试图通过斡旋其他交易来弥补损失。他最近的一笔交易是一个炼油厂项目。当他坐在酒店房间里和卡尤姆在一起时，他正在寻找石油投资者。
At some point Kayum gets a call on his cell phone from Habib, the informant, who Kayum knows only as a rich businessman. Just to clear up a confusing thing about the tape you're about to hear, Habib's full name is Mohamed Habib Rahman, and the government refers to him as Rahman. But his nickname is Haji, a term of respect for a Muslim who has made the Haj, the pilgrim's trip to Mecca. So other people call him Haji.
在某个时刻，卡尤姆接到了线人哈比卜打来的手机，卡尤姆只知道他是一个富有商人。为了理清你即将听到的录音中令人困惑的地方，哈比卜的全名是穆罕默德·哈比卜·拉赫曼（Mohamed Habib Rahman），政府称他为拉赫曼。但他的昵称是哈吉（Haji），这是一个对完成朝觐、前往麦加朝圣的穆斯林的尊称。所以其他人叫他哈吉。
So what happened was is that Kayum said that Haji is a very powerful man in America. He's worth himself but a few hundred million dollars. And maybe he can help you. Speak to him. So I say, oh, hi, Mr. Haji, hello. And then he tells me that, I believe that you are looking for a financier for a refinery project. So I thought he must be a powerful man.
事情是这样的，卡尤姆说哈吉在美国是一个非常有权势的人。他自己就有几亿美元的身家。也许他能帮你。和他谈谈。所以我说，噢，嗨，哈吉先生，你好。然后他告诉我，我相信你正在为一个炼油项目寻找融资方。所以我以为他一定是个有权势的人。
Of course, he was nothing of the sort. At this point, Rahman was making his living as an FBI informant, and had actually racked up a string of unpaid debts. But Lakhani knew none of this. So Rahman starts to feel Lakhani out, to see if he could be of interest to the FBI. He calls him over several months. Henry Klingeman, Lakhani's defense attorney, says at this point, the informant saw Lakhani as his meal ticket.
当然，他根本不是那种人。此时，拉赫曼靠做FBI线人为生，实际上还背负着一串未偿还的债务。但拉卡尼对此一无所知。所以拉赫曼开始试探拉卡尼，看看他是否能引起FBI的兴趣。他几个月里多次给他打电话。拉卡尼的辩护律师亨利·克林格曼（Henry Klingeman）说，此时，线人把拉卡尼视为他的“长期饭票”。
Meal ticket. Dupe. Patsy. Rahman is everything Lakhani is not. He's smart, he's savvy.
长期饭票。傻瓜。替罪羊。拉赫曼拥有拉卡尼所没有的一切。他聪明，他精明。
When Rahman reports back to the FBI, the information looks incredibly promising. He describes Lakhani as a major weapons trafficker to terrorist groups in at least five countries. Again, Henry Klingeman.
当拉赫曼向FBI报告时，信息看起来非常有希望。他形容拉卡尼是至少五个国家恐怖组织的重大武器贩子。再次提到亨利·克林格曼。
I'm looking at a set of handwritten notes prepared by the FBI agent who handled the informant. The notes are dated December 19, 2001, and they include his summary of what the informant said to him about Lakhani. Specifically that Lakhani was a main weapons trafficker, tied to Pakistani Indian criminals, Sri Lankan terrorists, Nepal and United Arab Emirates terrorists. That Lakhani is a broker of crude oil from Iraq. And, again, this was during the time of the embargo. Saddam Hussein was still in power and Iraqi oil was embargoed.
我正在查看负责该线人的FBI探员准备的一份手写笔记。笔记日期是2001年12月19日，其中包括他对线人关于拉卡尼所说的内容的总结。特别是拉卡尼是一个主要的武器贩子，与巴基斯坦印度的罪犯、斯里兰卡恐怖分子、尼泊尔和阿拉伯联合酋长国的恐怖分子有关联。拉卡尼是伊拉克原油的经纪人。而且，再次说明，这正是在禁运期间。萨达姆·侯赛因仍然当权，伊拉克石油当时处于禁运状态。
That Lakhani was supplying weapons to the Mujahideen, the holy warriors in Kashmir. That he was best friends with the Ukrainian prime minister, no name given. And that he was worth $300 to $400 million, meaning Lakhani. Lakhani, who lives in a semi-detached home in a London suburb, two old cars in the garage.
拉卡尼向克什米尔的圣战者提供武器。他自称是乌克兰总理的挚友，但没有给出名字。他声称身家有3亿到4亿美元，是指拉卡尼。拉卡尼住在一栋伦敦郊区的半独立式住宅里，车库里有两辆旧车。
With respect to what weapons Lakhani claimed he could sell, the agent's notes indicate that the informant told the agents that Lakhani could sell large-scale weapons, including missiles, anti-aircraft guns, any type of weapons.
关于拉卡尼声称他能出售什么武器，探员的笔记表明，线人告诉探员，拉卡尼能出售大规模武器，包括导弹、高射炮，任何类型的武器。
On January 17, 2002, Lakhani and Rahman finally meet for the first time in Newark. Now the investigation kicks into gear. The government surveillance tapes are rolling. They show grainy black and white images of Lakhani, sitting across a large table from Rahman. They're in a room at the Gateway Hilton, overlooking Newark airport. And clearly, Rahman is now trying to initiate a deal with Lakhani. And just as clearly, Lakhani is eager to oblige.
2002年1月17日，拉卡尼和拉赫曼终于在纽瓦克第一次见面。现在调查正式启动。政府的监控录音正在进行中。录音显示了拉卡尼坐在桌子对面与拉赫曼交谈的黑白颗粒感图像。他们在纽瓦克机场附近门户希尔顿酒店的一个房间里。显然，拉赫曼现在正试图与拉卡尼促成交易。同样显然的是，拉卡尼非常乐意配合。
The two men speak in Urdu and Hindi, and the translation sounds sort of like English Language Instructional videos. Rahman's translator is the first voice you'll hear.
两人用乌尔都语和印地语交谈，翻译听起来有点像英语语言教学视频。拉赫曼的翻译是你将听到的第一个声音。
Actually, the main thing is-
其实，最主要的是——
You mean the guns for fighting?
你是说用于战斗的枪支？
Yes, the guns, and the anti-aircraft guns.
是的，枪支，还有高射炮。
Yes, they are available.
是的，它们都有货。
Do you have something latest? Latest missiles? Something sinister, just like Stinger, with an effective range of at least 15,000 feet?
你有什么最新的吗？最新的导弹？某种凶猛的东西，就像毒刺那样的，有效射程至少在15,000英尺？
Yes, available.
是的，有货。
Give me the details about that one.
给我那个导弹的详细信息。
The main thing is the anti-aircraft gun.
最主要的是高射炮。
Yes, the anti-aircraft gun, and anything else you think is important. Ammo?
是的，高射炮，还有其他你认为重要的东西。弹药？
In ammo, I can give you whatever you want. Anything you ask for. Every gun and everything. As much as you want.
弹药的话，你要多少我就能给你提供多少。任何你要求的。每把枪等等。你要多少就有多少。
Do these people also have submarines?
这些人也有潜艇吗？
Yes, they are expert in this.
是的，他们是这方面的专家。
Good.
很好。
I mean this is a guy who promised to sell submarines to the informant, if the informant wanted them. That's the kind of thing that ought to make an FBI agent listing to the conversation just take his headphones off and shake his head. Why are we doing this? This guy is promising to sell submarines. It's preposterous.
我的意思是，这是一个如果线人想要，他就承诺卖给线人潜艇的家伙。这种事情本该让监听对话的FBI探员摘下耳机摇摇头。我们为什么要这么做？这家伙承诺卖潜艇。简直荒谬。
I mean, the one thing he didn't offer was an aircraft carrier, or a space shuttle, but if he had asked them for one, I'm sure he could tell you the Lakhani could get you both.
我的意思是，他唯一没提供的是航空母舰或航天飞机，但如果他们向他要，我相信他也能告诉你拉卡尼两样都能搞到。
Lakhani supposedly told the informant that he, meaning Lakhani, has people in the US government. And next to that it says, "obtains weapons, NVG." Which, as we've said, is night vision goggles. So the obvious implication is that Lakhani has contacts within our own government from whom he obtains weapons, including night vision goggles.
拉卡尼据称告诉线人，他，也就是拉卡尼，在美国政府内部有人。旁边写着“获取武器，NVG”。这正如我们所说，是夜视镜。所以显而易见的含义是，拉卡尼在我们自己的政府内部有联系人，并从中获取武器，包括夜视镜。
And also get me order for night vision goggles.
还要给我订单，夜视镜的。
What is that?
那是什么？
That's something for seeing at night.
那是夜间观察用的东西。
Are they buying it?
他们买吗？
Yes, they need a lot of them. It is their demand.
是的，他们需要很多。这是他们的需求。
What, sunglasses?
什么，太阳镜？
It is just evident that he has no idea what this guy is talking about. And they had a similar conversation about plutonium. Supposedly Lakhani bragged to the informant that he could get plutonium, in 22 pound bottles. Now how he came up with that increment, one can only imagine. But, in any event, the informant mentions PLU 135, which is plutonium. And, again, Lakhani betrays an absolute ignorance about what this guy is talking about.
很明显，他根本不知道这家伙在说什么。关于钚他们也有过类似的对话。据称拉卡尼向线人吹嘘他能搞到钚，装在22磅的瓶子里。至于他怎么想出这个增量的，人们只能想象。但无论如何，线人提到了PLU 135，也就是钚。同样，拉卡尼暴露了他对这家伙在说什么绝对的无知。
None of the claims that Rahman initially made about Lakhani checked out. Not one of them. Not that supposed arms deals, or the nuclear material, or the personal wealth. Though it's very possible that the source of this bad information was Lakhani himself. Klingeman describes his client as a name dropper, who associated himself with real events, and real people, but actually had nothing to do with them.
拉赫曼最初所说关于拉卡尼的一切指控，没有一条得到证实。一条都没有。无论是所谓的军火交易，还是核材料，或者是个人财富。尽管这些糟糕信息的来源很有可能就是拉卡尼本人。克林格曼将他的委托人描述为一个喜欢显摆的人，他将自己与现实事件和真实人物联系起来，但实际上与他们毫无关系。
To be sure, his bragging is boundless. Here's a small sample taken, mind you, from just one conversation.
可以肯定的是，他的吹牛是无边无际的。请注意，这里仅仅从一次对话中抽取的一小部分样本。
The richest man in London is Indian [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. I was the richest man. This was Lakhani in those days. When I used to get down at the airport, there was a red carpet for Lakhani. Red carpet. Not blue or green. A red carpet was given to me. Why? Because I was the most important man. I became very friendly with the royal family. And it's a fact. And they used to love me. [UNINTELLIGIBLE] is an [INAUDIBLE], you know that. I know him very well. Believe me.
伦敦最富有的人是印度人[听不清]。我曾是最富有的人。那是拉卡尼的时代。当我下飞机时，会有红地毯铺给拉卡尼。红地毯。不是蓝色或绿色。红地毯铺给我。为什么？因为我是最重要的人。我与皇室成员变得非常亲近。这是事实。他们过去很爱我。[听不清]是[听不清]，你知道的。我非常了解他。相信我。
He claimed to have lunch with Tony Blair at 10 Downing Street. Said he knew Libyan dictator Moammar Gaddafi, former Pakistani Prime Minister Benazir Bhutto. The Prime Minister of Sri lanka, the President of Congo. When I first visited him in prison, I asked if he really knew all these people. He told me, you want to meet Tony Blair? Give me 48 hours and he'll be in your house.
他声称在唐宁街10号与托尼·布莱尔吃过午餐。说他认识利比亚独裁者穆阿迈尔·卡扎菲、巴基斯坦前总理贝娜齐尔·布托。斯里兰卡总理、刚果总统。当我第一次去监狱探望他时，我问他是否真的认识所有这些人。他告诉我，你想见托尼·布莱尔吗？给我48小时，他就会出现在你家里。
So it's quite possible that Lakhani lied to Rahman about who he was. Or maybe Rahman exaggerated. Understandably, this isn't something the government wants to contemplate. Here's US attorney Chris Christie.
所以很有可能拉卡尼对拉赫曼撒了谎，说自己是谁。或者也许拉赫曼夸大了事实。可以理解的是，这不是政府愿意去考虑的事情。下面是美国联邦检察官克里斯·克里斯蒂。
Did you ever feel, at any point in the investigation, that he oversold Lakhani even a little bit, on some of those things that didn't seem to pan out. Like his $300 to $400 million net worth. That he was a major arms trafficker in numerous countries.
你在调查的任何阶段，有没有感觉到他甚至有一点点过度推销了拉卡尼，在那些没能实现的方面。比如他3亿到4亿美元的身家。比如他是一个在多个国家活动的重大军火贩子。
You know, listen, I'm not going to sit around and second guess it. What was done, was done, and I think, ultimately, the jury decided that question.
你知道，听着，我不会坐在那里去事后揣测。做过的事情已经做了，我认为陪审团最终决定了那个问题。
For Christie, it was enough that Lakhani knew Kayum, and that he had done at least one arms deal before he met the informant. That was enough experience in the arms trade to be suspicious.
对于克里斯蒂来说，拉卡尼认识卡尤姆，并且在遇到线人之前至少做过一笔军火交易，这就足够了。那种军火交易的经验足以让人怀疑。
Like if you came to me today, Petra, and said to me, Chris, get me a brochure on the Stinger missile, and see if you can fax it to me. Just because I'm doing this program, and if you could get it for me. You know, I wouldn't know the first place to start. Where do I get a brochure on a Stinger missile? Or on a Igla missile? I would have no idea where to start. I don't know if you'd have an idea of where to start. Lakhani knew.
就像你今天来找我，佩特拉，对我说，克里斯，给我一份毒刺导弹的宣传册，看看你能不能传真给我。就因为我正在做这个节目。你知道，我根本不知道从哪里开始。我去哪儿弄毒刺导弹的宣传册？或者是针式导弹？我完全不知道从哪开始。我不知道你是否知道从哪开始。拉卡尼知道。
Actually, if you Google the word "stinger, missile and brochure" you can find a Stinger sales brochure in a few seconds. And the one arms deal the government knew Lakhani was part of went like this. As an assistant to another broker, Lakhani had helped arrange the sale of some armored personnel carriers to Angola, for use by the president of Angola. Proper paperwork was filed with various governments. Everything was aboveboard. It was all perfectly legal.
实际上，如果你用谷歌搜索“毒刺、导弹、宣传册”这几个词，你几秒钟就能找到毒刺的销售宣传册。而且政府知道的拉卡尼参与的那唯一一笔军火交易是这样的。作为另一位经纪人的助理，拉卡尼曾帮助安排向安哥拉出售了一些装甲运兵车，供安哥拉总统使用。提交给了各个政府适当的文件。一切都在台面上。完全是合法的。
If you push Christie, he'll admit that at the end of the day, Lakhani wasn't exactly a criminal mastermind, or even a very good salesman. But he was the suspect they had. They couldn't predict where the next attack on America might come from. So they'd investigate Lakhani as aggressively as possible, to see where he might lead them, and who he might lead them to.
如果你逼问克里斯蒂，他会承认归根结底，拉卡尼并不是什么犯罪天才，甚至不是一个很好的推销员。但他就是他们拥有的嫌疑人。他们无法预测下一次对美国的攻击可能来自哪里。所以他们会对拉卡尼进行尽可能积极的调查，看看他可能会把他们引向哪里，以及他可能会把他们引向谁。
So they begin to ratchet up the case. The informant Rahman tells Lakhani he wants to order 200 missiles. But first Lakhani has to prove he can deliver. He needs to get just one, a sample, and he needs to ship it to Newark. There's talk of hundreds of thousands in profits, and a half million dollar bonus.
所以他们开始加大案件的力度。线人拉赫曼告诉拉卡尼他想订购200枚导弹。但首先拉卡尼必须证明他能交付。他需要先弄到一枚，作为样品，并且他需要把它运到纽瓦克。谈论着几十万美元的利润和五十万美元的奖金。
Then Rahman tells Lakhani that he represents a Somali terrorist group called the Ogaden Liberation Front. A real organization, by the way, but not a terrorist one. And at a certain point well into the deal, Rahman tells him the group wants to start Jihad in America, and throws in a reference to Al Qaeda for good measure. Lakhani, usually talkative on any subject, seems to have no reaction to this news. Boss, you have no idea how much money there is in this business, Rahman says.
然后拉赫曼告诉拉卡尼，他代表一个名为欧加登民族解放阵线的索马里恐怖组织。顺便说一句，这是一个真实的组织，但不是恐怖组织。在交易进行到一定阶段时，拉赫曼告诉他，该组织想在美国发动圣战，并顺便提到了基地组织作为补充。拉卡尼通常对任何话题都侃侃而谈，但对这个消息似乎没有任何反应。老板，你不知道这行里有多少钱，拉赫曼说。
If you ask Lakhani why he did it, he can't really explain. He says it wasn't ideological, or political, and he claims he didn't need the money. The best answer he came up with when my producer Sarah Koenig and I interviewed him was, well, Voodoo. And a lot of long distance phone calls.
如果你问拉卡尼为什么这么做，他真的解释不清楚。他说这不是意识形态或政治原因，他声称他不需要钱。当我的制片人莎拉·柯尼希（Sarah Koenig）和我采访他时，他能给出的最好的答案是，嗯，巫毒。还有很多长途电话。
By the second meeting, you had already agreed to try to get this stuff for him. Why did you do that?
到第二次见面时，你已经同意试着为他弄到这些东西了。你为什么要那样做？
Well, I told you it was a mistake.
嗯，我告诉过你这是一个错误。
To say it's a mistake-- it seems to be understating the activity. It's more than a mistake. It's a serious decision to enter into something that's potentially--
说这是一个错误——这似乎是在淡化那种活动。这不仅仅是一个错误。这是一个严肃的决定，去参与一些具有潜在——
You are interrupting me. You were interrupting me. Why--
你打断我了。你打断我了。为什么——
It's a legitimate question. There's a guy who you have some doubts about, he's asking you for things that you know are illegal, basically. You have other priorities with your oil deal, you are trying to get financing. Why do you bother to go forward with this guy?
这是一个合理的问题。你对某个人有一些怀疑，他正在向你要你明知道是非法的东西。你的石油交易还有其他优先事项，你正试图筹集资金。你为什么要和这个家伙继续下去？
Well, it happened. He induced me. You can call it inducing. He induced me, that's all I can tell you. I have no other reply.
嗯，事情发生了。他诱导我。你可以称之为诱导。他诱导了我，我只能告诉你这些。我没有其他回答。
What does that mean exactly, to you? How did he get to you? You were very worldly, you know many people, you've done these deals before. How is it that he is able to convince you?
这到底对你意味着什么？他是怎么让你上钩的？你阅历丰富，认识很多人，以前也做过这些交易。他是怎么能够说服你的？
He induced me, that's all I can tell you, he induced me. Nothing more. I was not greedy. I was not looking for extra money or big money or small money, because money is  no object in my life. But he induced me. Somehow he made some kind of magic on me, and I could not say no. Or whatever happened, I don't know. And he used to bother me like nobody's business. He would bother me 10 times a day. Sometimes, I can show you the transcript. Call number one, call number two, call number three, call number four, call number five. Five past 10, 5:11, 5:20. Three hundred telephone calls he has made. What about these? What about that?
他诱导了我，我只能告诉你这些，他诱导了我。没有别的了。我不贪婪。我不是在寻找额外的钱，或者大钱小钱，因为钱在我生活中不是问题。但他诱导了我。不知何故，他在我身上施了某种魔法，我无法拒绝。或者发生了什么，我不知道。而且他像没事人一样烦我。他一天会烦我10次。有时，我可以给你看文字记录。第一个电话，第二个电话，第三个电话，第四个电话，第五个电话。5点10分，5点11分，5点20分。他打了300个电话。那个怎么样？那个怎么样？
He just annoyed you into it?
他只是烦得你不得不做？
Not annoyed, but, you know, he would not leave me alone.
不是烦，但你知道，他就是不放过我。
Did you ever get suspicious that he was so persistent?
你有没有怀疑过他为什么这么执着？
Yes.
有。
Did you want him to like you?
你希望他喜欢你吗？
Well, I don't think anybody who dislikes me, in my life. Nobody dislikes me.
嗯，我不认为我这辈子有什么人讨厌我。没有人讨厌我。
Klingeman, his attorney, says Lakhani didn't seem at all bothered by the phone calls and attention. In fact, he says, his reaction was just the opposite.
他的律师克林格曼说，拉卡尼似乎完全没有被那些电话和关注打扰。事实上，他说，他的反应恰恰相反。
Fundamentally, what drove him was a desire to be part of something. He had failed in business. And, to a great extent, he had failed in life. He's an old man. And this was his chance to be part of something. He enjoyed the flattery, and the attention of the informant. And he enjoyed the phone calls. He enjoyed the globe trotting. And I think that, more than anything else, is what drove him.
从根本上说，驱动他的是一种成为某些事物一部分的渴望。他在生意上失败了。很大程度上，他在生活中也失败了。他是一个老人。这是他成为某些事情一部分的机会。他享受吹捧，享受线人的关注。他喜欢那些电话。他喜欢环球旅行。我认为这比其他任何事情都更驱动他。
Here was someone coming the Mr. Lakhani, a sad-sack Willy Loman of a character, and saying, you're a big boss. You're a big man. You have connections. Help me. And Mr. Lakhani has never heard this from anyone before.
这里有人来到拉卡尼先生，一个像威利·洛曼一样悲惨的人物面前，说，你是大老板。你是大人物。你有关系。帮帮我。拉卡尼先生以前从未从任何人那里听到过这些。
But was Lakhani just a sad sack? It's true, a lot of the business deals Lakhani bragged about seemed like complete fabrications, but some of them were real. And his wife, Kusum, showed me photos proving that he moved in some pretty fancy circles.
但拉卡尼只是个悲惨的人吗？确实，拉卡尼吹嘘的许多商业交易看起来完全是捏造的，但其中一些是真的。他的妻子库苏姆（Kusum）给我看了照片，证明他在一些非常高级的圈子里活动。
This is photo of Prince of Abu Dhabi, who came to play polo with Prince Charles. And we visited the grounds. Prince Charles is shaking hands with my husband. And I'm standing by on the side.
这是阿布扎比王子的照片，他来和查尔斯王子打马球。我们参观了场地。查尔斯王子正在和我丈夫握手。我站在一边。
But, then again, there are so many odd moments in the FBI tapes. Moments where Lakhani just seems out of his element. One minute he'd be talking about weapons systems, the next he'd be offering a diamond deal, or scrap metal, anything. Here's an exchange where Lakhani's weirdly candid about what he thought his first meeting with Rahman was going to be about. Lakhani is speaking first here.
但是，话又说回来，FBI录音里有太多奇怪的时刻。拉卡尼看起来完全不合群的时刻。一分钟他还在谈论武器系统，下一分钟他就会提供钻石交易，或废金属，任何东西。这里有一段交流，拉卡尼对自己认为第一次与拉赫曼的会面会谈什么感到奇怪地坦诚。拉卡尼在这里首先发言。
When you first met me, did you have any idea that you'll be doing this? How did this happen?
当你第一次见到我时，你有想过会做这种事吗？这是怎么发生的？
Yes, I was looking for a serious person. After meeting with you, I felt that this could also be done.
是的，我在寻找一个严肃的人。和你见面后，我觉得这也可以做。
OK. To be honest, my idea was this. You told me there were so many Mexican people and they eat a lot of mangoes. Do you remember the mangoes from India? It was my idea to import mangoes from India. I'm telling the truth.
好的。老实说，我的想法是这样的。你告诉我有很多墨西哥人，他们吃很多芒果。你还记得印度的芒果吗？我当时的想法是进口印度芒果。我说的是真话。
Mangoes. And then, without missing a beat, Lakhani goes right back to discussing weapons. Then there's this exchange about Indian sweets. To me, he seems like an insecure man here. Desperate to please. Again, Lakhani speaks first, and he mentions Kusum, his wife.
芒果。然后，毫不迟疑地，拉卡尼又回到了讨论武器上。然后还有这段关于印度甜点的交流。对我来说，他在这里看起来像是一个缺乏安全感的人。渴望取悦别人。再次，拉卡尼首先发言，他提到了他的妻子库苏姆。
Eat the sweets I brought for you, they are very high class. Try this one.
吃我带给你的甜点，它们是非常高级的。尝尝这个。
Wow.
哇。
Is it your favorite one?
这是你最喜欢的那种吗？
Yes, I like it very much.
是的，我非常喜欢它。
Yes, it is balushahi.
是的，它是巴鲁沙希（balushahi）。
This is my favorite.
这是我最喜欢的。
Kusum told me you would like it.
库苏姆告诉我你会喜欢它的。
Yes, I like it most.
是的，我最喜欢它。
Believe me, Kusum said you would like balushahi.
相信我，库苏姆说你会喜欢巴鲁沙希的。
Yes.
是的。
She was saying this sweet is very good. Even I did not know it.
她说这个甜点非常好。连我都没听说过。
Really, it is very delicious.
真的，它非常美味。
Kusum was saying so. I will call her right now and tell her that you like balushahi.
库苏姆是这么说的。我现在就打电话告诉她你喜欢巴鲁沙希。
That's what I told you.
那就是我告诉你的。
So she was right.
所以她是正确的。
Will you eat some?
你要吃一些吗？
Yes, definitely. Kusum was saying you will like it. Is it true?
是的，绝对。库苏姆说你会喜欢的。是真的吗？
Yes.
是的。
Oh. this is very tasty.
噢，这真是太美味了。
But ask US Attorney Chris Christie about it, and it turns out he reads the scene completely differently.
但问问美国联邦检察官克里斯·克里斯蒂，结果发现他完全是以不同的方式解读这一幕。
I absolutely agree with your description of him in that way, but I take something completely different from it. I don't think that he's this inane guy, which is what I'm getting from you. You're thinking, like, this inane idiot is sitting there talking about the sweets he got, And why doesn't he get to the missile deal already?
我完全同意你以那种方式对他的描述，但我从中得到的东西完全不同。我不认为他是个愚蠢的人，这就是我从你那里得到的结论。你觉得，就像，这个愚蠢的白痴坐在那里谈论他带来的甜点，为什么他不直接谈那个导弹交易呢？
But the fact of the matter is, Lakhani is trying to be a nice guy, a good guy. He's trying to get on this guy's good side no matter what he has to do to do it, because he wants to make the deal. This is the conduct of a person who's a salesman. I don't care what you're selling, whether it's a used car, women's clothing, or a missile. The deal is to get a customer who's willing to buy, and who buys from you. And he thinks this guy could go to somebody else if he gets frustrated with me, so I'm going to try to keep him close. And that's the way I view that interaction.
但事实是，拉卡尼是在试图做一个好人，一个好相处的人。无论他必须做什么，他都在努力争取这个人的好感，因为他想促成这笔交易。这是一个推销员的举动。我不管你在卖什么，无论是二手车、女装还是导弹。关键在于找到一个愿意购买、并且从你这里购买的客户。他觉得如果我对这个家伙感到沮丧，他可能会找别人，所以我要试着跟他保持密切联系。这就是我看待那种互动的方式。
Coming up, in the words of the old saying, keep your friends close, keep your shoulder fired surface-to-air missile closer, Our story about Hemant Lakhani continues in a minute. From Chicago public radio, and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，用那句老话来说，亲近你的朋友，让你的肩扛式地对空导弹更亲近。我们关于赫曼特·拉卡尼的故事一分钟后继续。来自芝加哥公共广播电台，和国际公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life , I'm Ira Glass. Today, we're devoting our whole show to the story of the government prosecution of Hemant Lakhani, on terrorism related charges. For nearly two years Lakhani spoke with government informant Mohamed Habib Rahman. Again here's Petra Bartosiewicz.
这是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天，我们将整个节目献给政府起诉赫曼特·拉卡尼的恐怖主义相关指控的故事。近两年来，拉卡尼一直与政府线人穆罕默德·哈比卜·拉赫曼通话。下面继续是佩特拉·巴托谢维奇。
It did seem Lakhani would say anything to please Rahman. Whatever item Rahman requested: anti-aircraft weapons, land mines, radioactive suitcase bombs, his answer was always the same. It is available. Here's Lakhani in the second meeting, promising to get Rahman Russian-made Igla missiles, the surface-to-air shoulder fired kind.
看起来拉卡尼为了取悦拉赫曼什么都肯说。无论拉赫曼要求什么：防空武器、地雷、放射性手提箱炸弹，他的回答总是相同的。有货。这是拉卡尼在第二次会议上，承诺为拉赫曼搞到俄制伊格拉（Igla）导弹，那种肩扛式地对空导弹。
How many do you want?
你想要多少？
About 200.
大约200个。
It will be done. It will be arranged immediately. I will go there on Sunday. The delivery will be ready on Monday.
没问题。我会立刻安排。我周日会去那里。周一就准备好交付。
He says this on April 25, 2002, that he'll deliver on Monday. But the truth is, Lakhani can't deliver on Monday. And he can't deliver for the next year. Lakhani's problem isn't just that he can't deliver the missile, it's that he can't actually acquire one. So even though he's promising Rahman the deal is nearly done, in fact, there is no deal. Month after month after month, he puts Rahman off and Rahman, understandably, is getting impatient.
他在2002年4月25日这么说，说他周一就会交付。但事实是，拉卡尼周一无法交付。他接下来一年也无法交付。拉卡尼的问题不仅是他无法交付导弹，而是他实际上根本搞不到一枚。所以尽管他向拉赫曼保证交易即将完成，事实上，根本没有交易。一个月接一个月，他一直拖着拉赫曼，而拉赫曼，可以理解的是，变得不耐烦了。
Here's Lakhani's attorney, Henry Klingeman again.
下面是拉卡尼的律师亨利·克林格曼再次发言。
In terms of the chronology, between January 2002 and August of 2003, there's a pattern. And there's no point in going conversation by conversation, because the conversations are all the same. The informant says, what's happening? Lakhani says, the deal is done. The informant says, well, where is the missile? Lakhani says it'll be here any day. And the missile never shows up. And the informant calls back two days later and says, what's happening? Lakhani says, the deal is done. The informant says, well, where's the missile? Lakhani says it will be here any day. And that just goes on and on and on.
从时间顺序来看，在2002年1月到2003年8月之间，有一个规律。没必要逐个对话去说，因为对话的内容都一样。线人说，怎么样了？拉卡尼说，交易做成了。线人说，好吧，导弹在哪？拉卡尼说快到了。导弹从来没出现。线人两天后又打来电话说，怎么样了？拉卡尼说，交易做成了。线人说，好吧，导弹在哪？拉卡尼说快到了。就这样一直持续下去。
Lakhani's one, and possibly only, weapons contact was the Ukrainian state controlled arms manufacturer. A company called Uker Spitz Export. This was the company the Lakhani got the armored personnel carriers from in the Angola deal. He showed Rahman their weapons brochures. But to buy missiles from them, he'd need special government paperwork, which he didn't have.
拉卡尼唯一可能也是仅有的武器联系人是乌克兰国有军工制造商。一家名为“乌克兰出口”（Uker Spitz Export）的公司。这就是拉卡尼在安哥拉交易中获得装甲运兵车的公司。他向拉赫曼展示了他们的武器手册。但要从他们那里购买导弹，他需要特殊的政府文件，而他没有。
So he started asking around in some shadier corners of the former Soviet republics. Apparently, he wasn't so subtle about it, because soon enough, the FSB, the Russian security service, caught wind of it, and started tracking Lakhani. Here's Chris Christie.
所以他开始在前苏联共和国的一些阴暗角落里打听。显然，他并不怎么谨慎，因为很快，俄罗斯安全局（FSB）就听到了风声，并开始跟踪拉卡尼。下面是克里斯·克里斯蒂。
At some point Russian law enforcement, the FSB, contacted the FBI to let them know that they knew Lakhani was contacting legitimate sources in the old Soviet union, in an attempt to buy these missiles. Well, I know at that point, for me, the light bulb really went on and I said, this guy's for real. He knew the right people to call.
在某个时刻，俄罗斯执法部门，FSB，联系了FBI，让他们知道他们知道拉卡尼正在联系前苏联的合法资源，试图购买这些导弹。嗯，我知道在那一点上，对我来说，灯泡真的亮了，我说，这个家伙是认真的。他认识该打电话找的人。
Still, Lakhani couldn't seem to get one. Months passed. The US government had given the Lakhani a buyer, but they were getting tired of waiting for him to drum up a seller. If only he'd find a missile their case could be done. So they get him a missile.
尽管如此，拉卡尼似乎还是没能搞到一枚。几个月过去了。美国政府给拉卡尼提供了一个买家，但他们开始厌倦等待他去拉到一个卖家。如果他能找到导弹，他们的案子就能结了。所以他们给他找了一个导弹。
They cook up a plan with the Russians. FSB agents posing as arms dealers sell Lakhani a dummy missile. Real in every respect, except that it had no munitions. Even an expert would have been fooled. Lakhani falls for it. He even watches the missile being loaded onto a ship in Saint Petersburg that he thinks will carry it to the US. What he didn't know was that the American government had spirited the phony missile onto an airplane. They eventually delivered it to Rahman's hotel room in Newark, in full view of the hidden FBI camera. When Lakhani saw it there, he was shocked.
他们与俄罗斯人策划了一个计划。FSB特工冒充军火商卖给拉卡尼一枚模拟导弹。除了没有弹药外，其他各方面都是真实的。甚至专家都会被骗倒。拉卡尼中计了。他甚至看着导弹在圣彼得堡被装上一艘他以为会运往美国的船。他不知道的是，美国政府已经把这枚假导弹秘密装上了一架飞机。他们最终把它送到了拉赫曼在纽瓦克的酒店房间，完全暴露在隐藏的FBI摄像机下。当拉卡尼在那里看到它时，他震惊了。
Not that it had arrived in New Jersey, but that it was luxuriating in a suite at the Gateway Hilton.
不是因为导弹运到了新泽西，而是因为它竟然奢侈地躺在门户希尔顿的一间套房里。
What were you expecting when you went to the hotel?
你去酒店时期待什么？
I was expecting to discuss everything that's all. I never thought that the missile would be sitting on the sofa.
我期待着讨论一切，就是这样。我从来没想过导弹会躺在沙发上。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Yes. That's why I said, that's it. I see the box lying exactly in the middle of the sofa. The big one. Not the two side one, but the middle one. I said. "He's a guest of you?" Like-- and I'm surprised. I told him, "How did it come?" He said, "Lakhani, I told you. In America you can smuggle anything." So I said, "You are a very powerful man, Mr. Haji." That's what I told him. And then he wanted to open it. And I said, no, don't open it, because I'm scared. But I don't know how do you open. Which is right side or wrong side. I don't know nothing about it.
是的。这就是为什么我说，就是它。我看到箱子正好躺在沙发中间。大的那个。不是两个小的那种，而是中间那个。我说，“它是你的客人？” 就像——我很惊讶。我告诉他，“它是怎么来的？” 他说，“拉卡尼，我告诉过你。在美国你可以走私任何东西。” 所以我说，“你是一个非常有权势的人，哈吉先生。” 那是我告诉他的。然后他想打开它。我说，不，别打开，因为我害怕。但我不知道你怎么打开它。哪边是右边，哪边是错的。我对它一无所知。
Here's the video of that moment. Lakhani speaks first.
这是那一刻的录像。拉卡尼首先发言。
That is so wonderful. Allah fulfilled your wish. The stuff arrived here. What a big thing.
真是太棒了。真主满足了你的愿望。东西到这了。真是件大事。
Please sit down.
请坐。
This box, how it arrive here?
这个箱子，它是怎么到这儿的？
Yes, it is here. Boss, what did I tell you? I told you that you can smuggle anything into America. Didn't I tell you?
是的，它在这。老板，我告诉过你什么？我告诉过你，你可以在美国走私任何东西。我没告诉过你吗？
Yes, the same box.
是的，同一个箱子。
That's right the same box.
没错，同一个箱子。
Yes, I raise my hands. I can't believe what we have done.
是的，我举起双手。我不敢相信我们做了什么。
Realizing the deal is almost finished, Lakhani becomes so delighted he leans over the box holding the missile, puts both his hands over his head, and shakes them around, as if he's trying to amuse a newborn baby.
意识到交易即将完成，拉卡尼变得非常高兴，他弯腰俯在装着导弹的箱子上，双手抱在头上，摇晃着，好像他在试图逗一个新生儿一样。
A few things seem clear here. First of all, he doesn't know the first thing about how this missile works. Not even which end is the shooting end. And it seems obvious he's never done anything like this before. He makes a few illegal weapon sales faux pas even your mother wouldn't make. Earlier in the deal, he'd offered to pay for the missile with a personal check. Later, he hand wrote an IOU for it to a Russian agent, using his full name. Hemant Shantilal Lakhani.
这里有几点很清楚。首先，他根本不知道这枚导弹是怎么工作的。甚至不知道哪一头是发射端。看起来很明显他以前从没做过这种事。他犯了几个连你母亲都不会犯的非法武器交易失礼行为。在交易早期，他甚至提出用个人支票支付导弹费用。后来，他亲手给俄罗斯特工写了一张欠条，用的是他的全名。赫曼特·尚蒂拉尔·拉卡尼（Hemant Shantilal Lakhani）。
But here's my favorite. Rahman is first here.
但我最喜欢这个。拉赫曼首先在这里发言。
Boss, here is another thing. It has a serial number.
老板，这里还有一件事。它有一个序列号。
What does it mean?
那意味着什么？
This is the serial number and we don't need it.
这是序列号，我们不需要它。
Why not?
为什么不？
Because.
因为。
It can be caught?
它会被查到吗？
It can be tracked from the serial number.
它可以通过序列号被追踪到。
It is good that you have told me.
你告诉我是对的。
Look here, I have removed it.
你看这里，我已经把它去掉了。
So you don't need it?
所以你不需要它？
Right.
对。
What's also clear, though, is that Lakhani knows perfectly well what Rahman wants to do with the missile. They've pulled the curtain back from the hotel window and are holding up the missile as they survey the airplanes parked on the tarmac at Newark airport.
不过，显而易见的是，拉卡尼完全知道拉赫曼想用这枚导弹做什么。他们拉开了酒店的窗帘，举起导弹，审视着停在纽瓦克机场停机坪上的飞机。
Boss, from here if four, five or six planes fall, what will happen?
老板，如果从这里掉下四、五或六架飞机，会发生什么？
They will be badly shaken.
它们会受到严重冲击。
What will happen to their economy?
它们的经济会发生什么？
If it happens 10 or 15 places simultaneously, at the same time.
如果10或15个地方同时发生，在同一时间。
You mean different airports at the same time?
你是说不同的机场同时发生？
Same time is very important. They will think the war has started.
同一时间非常重要。他们会以为战争开始了。
So he's putting on my shoulder. And he says, look, now from here you can see the airport and we can shoot. And he asks me, how many airports? I say, "Look, I only know JFK airport. I don't know, I've never traveled within American. So I can't tell you anything." He said, "No, no. 10 airport. And what is the best time?" I said, "The best time is-- the busiest time is either Monday or Friday." That's all I told him, which is the busiest time. Not the best time, busiest time.
所以他把它放在我的肩膀上。他说，看，现在从这里你可以看到机场，我们可以射击。他问我，多少个机场？我说，“看，我只知道肯尼迪机场。我不知道，我从来没在美国国内旅行过。所以我什么都不能告诉你。” 他说，“不，不。10个机场。什么时间最好？” 我说，“最好的时间是——最忙的时间要么是周一要么是周五。” 那是我告诉他的全部，最忙的时间。不是最好的时间，是最忙的时间。
To do what?
去做什么？
To shoot.
去射击。
Say, Sunday morning at 10 o'clock.
比如说，周日早上10点。
Like Sunday morning.
就像周日早上。
In the morning around 10:00 or 10:15 or 10:20, when all are still sleeping or whatever.
在早上10点左右，或者10:15或10:20，当所有人都还在睡觉或什么的。
What is the busiest day for flights?
航班最忙的日子是什么？
Monday.
周一。
Monday?
周一？
Yes, Monday or Friday.
是的，周一或周五。
You've got a missile on your shoulder, or he does, I don't know.
你的肩膀上有枚导弹，或者他有，我不知道。
He does.
他有。
He does, OK. And you're looking at airplanes. And he's saying when is the busiest time, and he's talking clearly about shooting down a commercial airplane.
他有，好的。你在看着飞机。他正在说什么时候最忙，他显然是在谈论击落一架商用飞机。
Who started this? September 17, he said, that I am buying this for the purpose of shooting civil airlines.
谁发起的这个？9月17日，他说，我买这个是为了击落民航客机的目的。
What did you think of this purpose? Did you think that was a good idea?
你觉得这个目的怎么样？你觉得这是个好主意吗？
Not at all. Well I thought he was joking.
完全不是。嗯，我以为他在开玩笑。
Sitting in jail, Lakhani went on to say that he had thought the weapons were to be used in Africa, in some tribal skirmishes in Kenya or Nigeria or wherever. But even his own lawyer told us he didn't buy that one. The tape of this last meeting on August 12, 2003 just peters out. That's because, at a certain point, Rahman leaves the room and six federal agents come in and arrest Lakhani.
坐在监狱里，拉卡尼接着说他以为这些武器将用于非洲，在肯尼亚或尼日利亚或其他地方的一些部落冲突中。但连他自己的律师都告诉我们，他不信那个。最后一次在2003年8月12日的会议录音就这样不了了之了。这是因为，在某个时刻，拉赫曼离开了房间，六名联邦特工进来逮捕了拉卡尼。
Once he understands the meetings are on tape, he pretty much confesses, saying something like, I'm sorry. You know everything. But even then Lakhani still didn't quite comprehend what was happening. Kusum told me, when she visited her husband in jail right after his arrest, he asked her where everyone else was. Why Rahman wasn't sharing a cell with him. And that's when she told him, there is no one else. You're it.
一旦他明白会议被录音了，他就差不多招供了，说了类似这样的话，我很抱歉。你知道一切。但即使那样，拉卡尼还是没完全理解发生了什么。库苏姆告诉我，当她在被捕后不久去监狱探望丈夫时，他问她其他人都在哪里。为什么拉赫曼没跟他关在一个牢房里。就在那时，她告诉他，没有别人了。只有你一个。
She said Lakhani was dumbfounded. He'd bought a fake missile, from a fake arms dealer, and delivered it to a fake terrorist. Every part of the crime had been supplied to him by the US government. That was almost two years ago. Lakhani's case went to trial in January this year. The only defense available to him was entrapment. That if the government hadn't set him up, he would have never supplied a missile to a terrorist group, or anyone else.
她说拉卡尼目瞪口呆。他从一个假军火商那里买了一枚假导弹，并把它交付给了一个假恐怖分子。犯罪的每一个部分都是由美国政府提供给他的。那是近两年前的事了。拉卡尼的案子今年1月进入审判。他唯一能用的辩护是“诱捕”。即如果不是政府设局，他绝不会向恐怖组织或任何人提供导弹。
At trial, the state would have to prove that Lakhani was ready, and willing, to do the deal. Or that he was able to actually get the missile. Lakhani's lawyer told jurors that although he may be loathsome, and an idiot, of the requirements, Lakhani was only willing, not ready. And certainly not able. Here's Lakhani's lawyer Henry Klingeman.
在审判中，州政府必须证明拉卡尼已经准备好并愿意促成这笔交易。或者他实际上有能力搞到导弹。拉卡尼的律师告诉陪审员，虽然他可能令人厌恶，是个白痴，但对于那些要求，拉卡尼只是“愿意”，而不是“准备好”。当然更不“具备能力”。下面是拉卡尼的律师亨利·克林格曼。
The entrapment defense is designed for people who are morally guilty to be legally not-guilty. In terms of a legal defense, this was a great defense on September 10, when cooler heads might have prevailed. Because he was clearly entrapped.
诱捕辩护旨在让在道德上有罪的人在法律上被认定为无罪。作为一种法律辩护，这在9月10日是一个极好的辩护，当时冷静的头脑可能占了上风。因为他显然是被诱捕的。
Unfortunately for Lakhani, it was well past September 11. And what jurors saw was a man talking enthusiastically about shooting down airplanes. But the government's best weapon at the trial was the weapon itself. On the first day, FBI agents carried in a wooden box shaped like a coffin, and set it down with a thud in front of the jury. Then the prosecutor opened the box, and piece by piece, took out the missile. A long green steel tube.
不幸的是，那已经是9月11日之后了。陪审员看到的是一个兴致勃勃地谈论击落飞机的人。但政府在审判中最有效的武器就是那个武器本身。第一天，FBI特工搬进来一个棺材形状的木箱，沉重地放在陪审团面前。然后检察官打开箱子，把导弹一件件拿出来。一个长长的绿色钢管。
Donna, a bank executive, was one of the jurors. She asked that we not use her last name.
唐娜（Donna），一位银行高管，是陪审员之一。她要求我们不要使用她的姓氏。
I am known as juror number six from the Lakhani that took place in Newark, New Jersey. I listened very intently to both sides of the argument, and day number one I hadn't passed judgment. I was just very focused on making sure I took as many notes, and not to let my emotions sway. Because as soon as I started to hear the bad things being said about America, and Americans-- and I'm very patriotic-- they upset me.
我是拉卡尼案的6号陪审员，案件在新泽西州纽瓦克审理。我非常认真地听取了双方的辩论，第一天我没有做出判断。我非常专注于确保我尽可能多地做笔记，不让情绪左右自己。因为当我开始听到关于美国和美国人的坏话时——我非常爱国——他们让我很难受。
When I saw the missile being brought into the courtroom. They took it out and they passed it by the jurors, I cringed. Every time I saw the box, I cringed.
当我看到导弹被带进法庭时。他们把它拿出来，从陪审员面前传过去，我感到战栗。每次我看到那个箱子，我就感到战栗。
Donna soon found the evidence overwhelming. So did everybody else. Everybody except one person.
唐娜很快发现证据确凿。其他人也是如此。除了一个人。
My name is Gussie Burnett. I'm 65 years old. I work for the Newark public schools and I'm a librarian.
我叫格西·伯内特（Gussie Burnett）。我65岁。我在纽瓦克公立学校工作，是一名图书馆员。
Burnett, juror number nine, was the lone holdout.
伯内特，9号陪审员，是唯一坚持反对的人。
As far as I'm concerned, it was entrapment if he didn't actually do anything.
就我而言，如果他实际上什么都没做，那就是诱捕。
Some of the other jurors seem to think that Lakhani actually could have done this, that he could have gotten that missile if he tried long enough.
其他一些陪审员似乎认为拉卡尼实际上能做到这一点，如果他足够努力，他能搞到那枚导弹。
But did he try for 22 months and then get one? After offering all this-- millions of dollars. And he couldn't get a missile? No, he wasn't going to never get no missile. And they knew he wasn't going to get one, either. That's why they bought it. And set it right there in his lap. They just-- from day one, I just can't understand it. They came in and they sit down and they say, this man's guilty, guilty, guilty, guilty, guilty, guilty. They didn't even think about it. Hey, wait a minute. Let's analyze these things. Just go one by one.
但他在22个月里努力了吗？然后得到了一枚？在提供了所有这些——数百万美元之后。他搞不到一枚导弹？不，他永远也搞不到导弹。他们也知道他搞不到。这就是为什么他们买下它。并把它直接放在他的膝盖上。他们只是——从第一天起，我就是无法理解。他们走进来坐下说，这个人有罪，有罪，有罪，有罪，有罪，有罪。他们甚至没有思考过。嘿，等等。让我们分析一下这些事情。一个个来。
For a few hours, Burnett held her ground. It didn't go so well.
有几个小时，伯内特坚持住了立场。结果不太好。
So I say, he's guilty. Someone says, he's not guilty. And I say, he's guilty, because look at page 48. And then someone else would say, well look at page 52. So everyone tried to make themselves heard. Voices started to rise so could be heard over the crowd.
所以我说，他有罪。有人说，他无罪。我说，他有罪，因为看第48页。然后别人会说，好吧，看看第52页。所以每个人都试图让自己被听到。声音开始升高，以便能盖过人群。
The juror who felt that he was not guilty, I think felt overwhelmed by probably a good six, seven, eight jurors talking loudly at the same time, that actually turned into screaming to be heard. It was probably very intimidating for her.
我觉得那位认为他无罪的陪审员，感到被大约六、七、八个同时大声说话的陪审员淹没了，实际上变成了尖叫以求被听到。这对她来说可能非常具有恐吓性。
Because it was all directed at her.
因为一切都针对她。
Correct. Because she was the only one that thought that he was not guilty.
没错。因为她是唯一一个认为他无罪的人。
Pretty soon, Burnett changed her vote.
很快，伯内特改变了她的投票。
This is how that happened. I just closed on  a house in Virginia. And everybody in the jury room knew it  because the court was closed down on April 25, so I could go close on the house. So when we came back, I think we started deliberating on a Wednesday.
事情是这样发生的。我刚在弗吉尼亚州买了一套房子。陪审团里的每个人都知道，因为法院在4月25日关闭了，所以我可以去处理购房手续。所以当我们回来时，我想我们是在周三开始审议的。
And we got to one count. And I said, the man not guilty. Now, ain't nobody going to change my mind. And the jury foreman said, if I didn't go along with them, I wouldn't see the inside of my house until December. So I said, oh, what the hell? He don't mean nothing to me, the man guilty.
我们谈到了一项指控。我说，这个人无罪。现在，没人能改变我的想法。陪审团工头说，如果我不配合他们，我就别想在十二月之前见到我的房子。所以我说，哦，管他呢？他对我毫无意义，这个人有罪。
But I know it was wrong. It wasn't right for them to do that man like that. It wasn't right. But it's over now.
但我知道那是错的。他们那样对待那个人是不对的。那是不对的。但现在结束了。
Are you saying you regret your decision, to find him guilty?
你是说你后悔你的决定，判他有罪？
I, uh-- yeah. Yeah. I really do. Because as far as I'm concerned, the man was entrapped. I should have held out.
我，呃——是的。是的。我真的很后悔。因为就我而言，那个人是被诱捕的。我本应该坚持住。
So the only person who bought Lakhani's defense, caved in the jury room. It took just over seven hours. The jury found him guilty. In the end, the government spent almost two years, and hundreds of thousands of dollars, trapping a man who didn't seem to have any connection to any real terrorists, or terrorist sympathizers.
所以唯一一个采信了拉卡尼辩护的人，在陪审团室里屈服了。只用了七个多小时。陪审团认定他有罪。最终，政府花了近两年时间，和数十万美元，诱捕了一个似乎与任何真正的恐怖分子或恐怖主义同情者没有任何联系的人。
Chris Christie says it's his main regret about the case. That Lakhani didn't lead them to any other suspects. We asked Christie if maybe the problem wasn't that Lakhani refused to talk, but that he simply didn't know anything. I guess it's possible, Christie said. Even so, he's happy with the outcome, because it proves that law enforcement is meeting its new mandate.
克里斯·克里斯蒂说这是他对此案最大的遗憾。拉卡尼没有把他们引向任何其他嫌疑人。我们问克里斯蒂，问题是不是不在于拉卡尼拒绝交谈，而在于他根本不知道任何事。我想这是可能的，克里斯蒂说。即便如此，他对结果感到满意，因为这证明执法部门正在实现其新的任务授权。
What Lakhani is emblematic of in the war on terrorism is, in the biggest way, the new American approach to law enforcement in the area of terrorism. We're going to try to catch people before they act.
拉卡尼在反恐战争中的象征意义在于，在最大程度上，是美国在恐怖主义领域新的执法方式。我们要试着在人们行动之前抓住他们。
But this very policy, as good as it sounds, is what worries people like Henry Klingeman.
但正是这项政策，听起来再好，也正是让亨利·克林格曼这样的人担心的东西。
You could probably go to the Middle East and collar a random person on the street, and ask them what they think of America, and ask them what they would do if they were given the ability to send missiles to the United States. And you could probably find millions of people, sadly, who would say, I'd do it in a heartbeat. You wouldn't even have to pay me, and I would do it.
你大概可以去中东，随便抓一个街上的人，问问他们对美国的看法，问问他们如果被给予向美国发射导弹的能力会做什么。你大概能找到数百万悲哀的人会说，我会毫不犹豫地做。你甚至不需要付钱给我，我就会做。
Now, on the government's theory, we'd arrest all those people, because they are willing to participate in this type of activity. And we'd say, well, we stopped them before they were able to actually do it. But those people may or may not be capable of getting involved in Jihad, whoever they are. On the streets of Ramallah, on the streets of Kabul or wherever.
现在，按照政府的理论，我们会逮捕所有这些人，因为他们愿意参与这类活动。我们会说，好吧，我们在他们真正能够付诸行动之前阻止了他们。但这些人可能具备也可能不具备参与圣战的能力，无论他们是谁。在拉马拉街头，在喀布尔街头或者任何地方。
But Mr. Lakhani was not in that position and was not inclined to do this type of thing. He was all too willing to do it when asked, but he was never going to do it until he was asked. And no one was going to ask him. Because no real terrorist would ever go to Mr. Lakhani and ask him for anything. So, if the government's going to go out and apprehend people before they even think about this stuff, or maybe, after they think about it, before they ever do anything about it, then we might as well put barbed wire around the entire Middle East. Because that's really the logical conclusion of that policy.
但拉卡尼先生并没有处于那种位置，也没有倾向于做这类事情。当被要求时，他非常愿意去做，但在被要求之前他绝不会去做。也没有人会去要求他。因为没有真正的恐怖分子会去向拉卡尼先生求助任何东西。所以，如果政府要出去在人们甚至思考这些事情之前，或者也许在他们思考之后，在他们真正采取任何行动之前就逮捕他们，那么我们还不如给整个中东围上铁丝网。因为那才是该政策的逻辑结论。
Ask Christy about this, and he says what might have been in Lakhani's case, whether he could have ever gotten the missile, isn't even relevant.
问问克里斯蒂关于这一点，他说在拉卡尼案中可能发生的事情，他是否真的能搞到导弹，甚至不是相关的。
You're saying that he is a person who facilitates terrorist activity. But, actually, he's a person who potentially might have facilitated. I mean, the fact is, there actually wasn't a terrorist group, there wasn't a missile, he didn't do this deal. So is the question-- I guess you see him as someone who really would have been approached by a terrorist. But I'm not sure where the evidence is for that. How do you make that argument, really? It seems like it's all speculation to say he might have turned into a bad guy.
你说他是一个促进恐怖活动的人。但是，实际上，他是一个可能潜在促进的人。我的意思是，事实是，实际上没有恐怖组织，没有导弹，他也没有做这笔交易。所以问题是——我猜你把他看作一个真正会被恐怖分子接触的人。但我不知道证据在哪里。你怎么能真正提出那个论点？说他可能会变成一个坏人似乎全是猜测。
No, I disagree with you. He was a bad guy. Once you find someone who is that basically amoral, then whether or not he was actually able to do it, that debate, which I have one opinion of and the defense has another opinion of, and maybe you have a slightly different opinion, who cares? I mean at the end, who cares? I don't have a crystal ball. And I don't know if this had fallen apart, what Hemant Lekhani. Lakhani would have done next.
不，我不同意你的观点。他是个坏人。一旦你发现某人基本上是那样道德沦丧，那么他是否真的有能力做到，那场辩论——我有一个观点，辩方有另一个观点，也许你有稍微不同的观点——谁在乎呢？我的意思是最后，谁在乎呢？我没有水晶球。而且我不知道如果这笔交易泡汤了，赫曼特·拉卡尼接下来会做什么。
So the question is, confronted with those realities, as an American law enforcement, what do we do? Do we ignore it, because we say, eh, maybe he could, maybe he couldn't. Let's see. Let's see if he does. I'm just not willing to take that chance. And I think most Americans would say the same thing. Hemant Lakhani was willing to sell missiles to a person he believed to be a terrorist. Who expressly said he was going to use them to kill innocent people.
所以问题是，面对这些现实，作为美国执法者，我们做什么？我们忽略它吗？因为我们说，呃，也许他能，也许他不能。让我们看看。让我们看看他是否会做。我只是不愿意冒这个险。而且我认为大多数美国人会说同样的话。赫曼特·拉卡尼愿意向他认为是恐怖分子的人出售导弹。那个人明确表示他要用它们来杀害无辜的人。
And so there are good people and bad people. Bad people do bad things. Bad people have to be punished. These are simple truths. Bad people must be punished, and so, he's not just a guy with four beers in him at the corner bar, who says, yeah, if I could get a missile and I'd sell  it to whoever if could make a buck. That's not who we're talking about here.
所以有好人也有坏人。坏人做坏事。坏人必须受到惩罚。这些是简单的真理。坏人必须受到惩罚，所以，他不仅仅是一个在街角酒吧喝了四杯啤酒，说“是的，如果我能搞到一枚导弹，我愿意把它卖给任何能付钱的人”的家伙。那不是我们在这里谈论的人。
So let's not minimize him either. He's not Osama Bin Laden. But, you know, let's not make him Elmer Fudd, either. All I know is that he's not the kind of guy I want coming through Newark airport. He's not the kind of guy I want in this country. That's the kind of guy I want in federal prison. So that's where he's going to go.
所以让我们也不要小看他。他不是奥萨马·本·拉登。但是，你知道，也别把他当成埃尔默·福德（Elmer Fudd）。我只知道他不是我想要经过纽瓦克机场的那种人。他不是我想要在这个国家的那种人。那就是我想要送进联邦监狱的那种人。所以那就是他要去的地方。
And, at the end, that's the success of the Lakhani case.
而且，最终，这就是拉卡尼案的成功之处。
In Washington, the Lakhani case is seen as one of the most successful prosecutions in the war on terror. It was one of three cases the Justice Department cited in testimony before Congress when the Patriot Act came up for renewal, as an example of proactive, preemptive prosecution. But what's so hard to figure out is whether the government's methods are actually working.
在华盛顿，拉卡尼案被视为反恐战争中最成功的起诉之一。这是司法部在国会作证《爱国者法案》续期时引用的三个案例之一，作为主动、预防性起诉的例子。但最难弄清楚的是政府的方法是否真的有效。
In 2005, President Bush said that over 400 people had been charged with terrorism-related crimes since the September 11 attacks. And that in over half of those cases, the defendants were convicted or pled guilty. But an investigation by The Washington Post , which spent six months examining almost every case, found that in reality only 39 people, not 200, had been convicted of terrorism or national security related crimes. And only 14 were connected to Al Qaeda. Lakhani was counted as one of those 14.
2005年，布什总统表示，自9/11袭击以来，已有400多人被指控犯有恐怖主义相关罪行。在这些案件中，超过一半的被告被定罪或认罪。但《华盛顿邮报》的一项调查花了六个月时间审查了几乎每一个案件，发现实际上只有39人，而不是200人，被判犯有恐怖主义或国家安全相关罪行。只有14人与基地组织有联系。拉卡尼被算作那14人之一。
Petra  Bartosiewicz. She's writing a book about terrorism trials since 9/11 called The Best Terrorists We Could Find . Her story was first broadcast in 2005.
佩特拉·巴托谢维奇。她正在写一本关于9/11后恐怖主义审判的书，名为《我们能找到的最好恐怖分子》。她的故事于2005年首次播出。
Hemant Lakhani is now 74 years old, and has at least another 35 years left on his prison sentence. The US Attorney in the Lakhani case, Chris Christie, is now running for the Governor of New Jersey. On his official campaign website, the Lakhani case is listed in a section of his major accomplishments, under "Cases that made a difference."
赫曼特·拉卡尼现在74岁了，他的刑期还至少剩下35年。拉卡尼案中的美国联邦检察官，克里斯·克里斯蒂，现在正在竞选新泽西州州长。在他的官方竞选网站上，拉卡尼案被列在他主要成就的一个章节中，标题为“产生影响的案件”。
The number of terrorism cases has risen since 2005 from 400. As of May 2009 it stands at 720 according to the Center on Law and Security at NYU Law School. Cases where informants bait the suspects into committing a terrorist act, like the Lakhani case, or the recent Newburgh case that we talked about at the top of the program, are just a small number of these prosecutions. Maybe a dozen is the best estimate.
自2005年以来，恐怖主义案件的数量已从400起上升。截至2009年5月，据纽约大学法学院法律与安全中心统计，这一数字为720起。像拉卡尼案，或我们节目开头讨论的近期纽堡案那样，线人诱导嫌疑人进行恐怖主义行为的案件，只是这些起诉中的一小部分。大概一打是最好的估计。
But Aziz Huq, the University of Chicago Law School assistant professor that we heard at the beginning of our program, says these are the high profile cases. These are the ones that appear above the fold in the newspaper.
但我们在节目开始时听到的芝加哥大学法学院助理教授阿齐兹·哈克说，这些是备受瞩目的案件。这些是出现在报纸头版头条的案件。
These are the cases that are propelling public debate, right? These are the cases where you have the Attorney General, the Mayor of New York, standing up and, if not thumping the table, then saying in a loud and declarative voice, there continues to be a significant, domestic terrorism threat in the United States.
这些是推动公众辩论的案件，对吧？这些案件中，司法部长、纽约市长站出来，即使没有拍桌子，也用响亮而明确的声音说，美国仍然存在严重的国内恐怖主义威胁。
Is there any kind of sense that the new administration, the Obama administration, is going to discourage these kind of cases. Or are they just chugging right along with this?
有没有一种感觉，新政府，奥巴马政府，会阻止这些类型的案件。还是他们只是在继续进行？
The Obama administration hasn't changed, I think, as much as its supporters either hoped or thought it would. I think it's very unlikely that we will see significant change under the Holder Justice Department.
我不认为奥巴马政府比其支持者希望或认为的改变得那么多。我认为在霍尔德（Holder）司法部下，我们不太可能看到重大变化。
If you were to redirect the way all that Justice Department force is being applied, what would you do? Where would you send them?
如果你要重定向司法部所有力量的应用方式，你会怎么做？你会把他们派到哪里？
I think that the way that informants are used in the United States is, at the end of the day, counterproductive. The FBI and state and local law enforcement, have been using informants for decades. Take that very successful tactic that's been used in the drug context, been used in the organized crime context, transplant it into the terrorism context, and what happens?
我认为在美国使用线人的方式，归根结底是适得其反的。FBI和州及地方执法部门几十年来一直在使用线人。采用在毒品背景下使用过、在有组织犯罪背景下使用过的那种非常成功的战术，移植到恐怖主义背景下，结果会怎样？
Well, you start sending out your informants. Those informants are under considerable pressure to find conspiracies. And it's just not easy. It's not easy to do that in the way that it's straightforward to do in the organized crime context, and the drug context. There just aren't as many terrorists as there are drug runners or mafia kingpins in the United States, right?
嗯，你开始派出你的线人。那些线人承受着寻找阴谋的巨大压力。这并不容易。在恐怖主义背景下，不像在有组织犯罪背景和毒品背景下那样直接。在美国并没有像毒贩或黑手党头目那样多的恐怖分子，对吧？
And, in addition, if you are actually part of a sleeper cell, why are you going to talk to this bozo who drives up in his Mercedes, and seems like he looks just like a government informant? I know in the Newburgh case, the assistant Imam of one the mosques told the press, we all just, we thought the guy in the nice car, we assumed he was a government informant.
此外，如果你实际上是一个潜伏组织的一部分，你为什么要和一个开着梅赛德斯过来，看起来就像政府线人的笨蛋交谈？我知道在纽堡案中，其中一座清真寺的助理阿訇告诉媒体，我们大家都认为开豪车的那个人是政府线人。
The use of informants, as we see from the Lakhani case, as we see from the Newburgh case, is not going to target the smart terrorist. It's going to target individuals who are marginal, who are vulnerable to suggestion. It's going to target, quite frankly, people who are a little dim.
使用线人，正如我们从拉卡尼案中看到的，正如我们从纽堡案中看到的，不会针对聪明的恐怖分子。它会针对处于边缘、易受暗示影响的个人。坦率地说，它会针对那些有点迟钝的人。
Our program was produced today by Sarah Koenig and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, Jane Feltes and Lisa Pollak. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Seth Lind is our production manager. Production help from Todd Bachmann, Laura Bellows and Aaron Scott. Our music consultant each week is Jessica Hopper.
今天的节目由莎拉·柯尼希和我自己制作，还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、戴安·库克（Diane Cook）、简·费尔特斯（Jane Feltes）和莉萨·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。阿德里安·马蒂奥韦茨（Adrianne Mathiowetz）运营我们的网站。塞思·林德（Seth Lind）是我们的制作经理。制作协助来自托德·巴赫曼（Todd Bachmann）、劳拉·贝洛斯（Laura Bellows）和亚伦·斯科特（Aaron Scott）。我们每周的音乐顾问是杰西卡·霍珀（Jessica Hopper）。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for a program, by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who usually calls me by one of these names: "Meal ticket, dupe, patsy." I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。WBEZ对节目的管理监督由我们的老板，托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生负责，他通常会用这些名字之一称呼我：“长期饭票、傻瓜、替罪羊。” 我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。